[Music]
I first met Hugh through his writing
actually a friend of mine recommended
the silo series and immediately when I
got into it we actually have the first
book of the silo series here well I
realized it was a completely fresh look
at the apocalypse that it's pretty rare
that I get surprised by an apocalypse
story but we we then came to meet him I
think through a Stewart Brand met Hugh
up at an event that Jeff Bezos was doing
a campfire event right and so we've got
this conversation going and as we were
starting this library here for for the
interval this is called the manual for
civilization which is so far the first
1,200 books that we've selected that you
would most want to restart civilization
and for those of you who've read the
silo series you'll know that it has a
kind of a perfect place in that space
and when we when I finally got to meet
you he was very nice and had a an
addition one of one made of the whole
silo series for the library which we
have up here so we actually keep on the
Shelf that nobody gets I thought you'd
already lost them I was like there now
you think you think Prince can last
forever and I'm like they're already
gone yes now they're right there so when
when I found out that he was coming to
town I really wanted him to give a talk
and surprisingly he wanted to give a
talk on the the impermanence of books
digital maybe which is a topic that we
have played around with since 1998 with
long now but really looking at it from
the other side and a lot of our
preconceptions were coming from the
early days of digital and and digital
has changed a lot and Hugh has been at
the forefront of the modern digital
publishing he was kind of the first star
that came out of a digital only
publishing model but not the biggest
star the biggest star of that age is in
the audience it's Andy weir if y'all
haven't read the
yeah please read the Marcin before the
movie comes out so you can be that
hipster and then when the movie comes
out take the whole family because you
know we probably gets like 1.5 percent
of gross so we need like a lot of people
to go so that he's he can buy rounds for
everybody next time he's here yes and
he's been and he's been nice enough to
also agree to and talk to me coming up
here in the fall so Andy will be
negotiating the percentage for the talk
later so when when Hugh suggested this
talk it immediately kind of Rose my
hackles and then I also realized that
some of my preconceptions that I've been
holding on to around digital data since
the 90s are actually wrong and so it was
a good chance for for us to to to
rethink that and so he put together this
talk just for us and also just for him
the power supply for the chalkboard
robot died halfway through the drawing
so the the discussion of how but the
digital still exists the digital point
but the physical has been ruined right
so first point goes to Hugh Hugh do we
have chalk like loose chalk if I need to
draw anything okay okay let's do this
all right I love the tile of the title
of my talk cuz I'm an author and I'm in
a place called the interval so we're
gonna talk about words and time I'm also
gonna expand on how I met Stuart really
quickly I was going to an event and they
tell you who's gonna be there and and I
it's it's a who's who of all these
awesome people and and my my
ex-girlfriend could tell you that the
person I freaked out about was like oh
my god Stuart brand is gonna be at this
event I've got to meet him and I get to
the event and a friend of mine comes up
to me and says I've got a fan it really
wants to meet you and I'm thinking like
not now I'm looking for Stuart brand and
the fan that he brings to me is Stuart
and like and then he comes you know like
just like you know he's always all
smiles and and bouncing like a
twelve-year-old and I and we've just
fanboy about each other's work so that's
how that's why I'm here
thank you for having me it's it's been
such a great friendship for the I don't
know one year that we've had it so I'm
excited to be here I'm going to talk
about what I call the library that lasts
I think there's a moral imperative to
this and but first my my publishing
career has always been thinking about
time and books because when I first
started I was so impatient because of
the advantages of digital publishing I
wanted things done immediately and I
worked with a small press and things
were going very slow so the reason I
started self-publishing was because I
knew I could do it myself and do it very
quickly so now I'm much more patient and
I was very patient by the time my second
book came out because what I realized
was I'm not gonna be on Oprah with my
first book I wasn't gonna make a lot of
money but it didn't matter the fact that
no one was discovering my book meant it
was brand new it could sit there forever
online and this gave me the the courage
to write another book even though my
second my first a second book weren't
selling that much the reason this is is
like even print-on-demand
books which are digital because they're
PDFs are don't go out of print you know
used to be after six months if you're
not selling well they would take your
books off the shelf and go burn them
later pulping them but it really was
someone's job to take unopened boxes of
books and throw them in a furnace for a
while and with ebooks of course they're
gonna be around as long as Amazon's
around with
we'll probably be around Steve Jeff
Bezos +10 you know that's about how long
it takes for the next guy to run a
company into the ground
I set a really funny I said a long-term
goal you can't say that in the interval
when you're talking ten years like
people laugh cuz that's a sneeze but for
writing I said a long-term goal of ten
years I was gonna write two novels a
year for ten years and before I even
assessed my career that's the kind of
patience I was looking at Andy's
freaking out cuz any rights one book in
ten years you bastard like what are you
doing here he's be at home writing I
want the next book another thing I was
inspired by now it's really hard to
write in obscurity I think Andy can
attest to this well everybody except
these two guys have been famous since
they started writing a magazine a couple
years ago it's really difficult to write
every day with no one reading your stuff
or giving you any kudos so I started
thinking really long term and I would
lie to myself and say that I'm gonna be
the next philip k dick and no one's
gonna have heard of me until I'm dead
and then like a thousand years from now
they're gonna make a movie out of
everything that I wrote now it doesn't
it doesn't matter if this is actually
true or not what matters is that you can
fool yourself into getting up and
writing every day because there's the
chance that you could be discovered this
wasn't this is a very serious thing for
writers to consider because this was not
true 10 years ago you know five years
before I started writing if I didn't
make it no one was gonna look in my
drawer and find a manuscript and have it
discovered now all these undiscovered
authors and and nonfiction fiction
bloggers their content is there a lot of
us can be discovered after they're dead
because this is a new transition we I
know authors that have already given up
on writing only to have their book hit a
bestseller list afterward and they get
back into writing that's unheard of but
it's already happening I'm gonna talk
about problems with paper so what I
meant
Stewart and I think you're the first one
who told were you the one who told me
about the book you wanted a copy of wool
or
okay so they're gonna they're gonna make
this book safe I thought they'd already
lost it I think they put it up there
because they know it's a one of one and
so it's probably worth at least the
cover price
so we're gonna these books are gonna
last 10,000 years I come into the
interval a year ago and I'm like okay so
you put my book on the San Andreas Fault
Line at sea level and you have Molotov
cocktails hanging from the ceiling like
who's who's really shitty idea was this
for making these books last I mean why
like I come in the books on like a lower
shelf over there like people are
thumbing through it and spilling bourbon
on it and I'm like that that's where
this talk has come from saying this we
do suffer from survivor bias with with
everything that lasts archaeologically
like we think people use stone tools
they use the wood tools we just don't
see them anymore we write a narrative of
what's left over so there's all these
Greek philosophers that we only know
their name because some other
philosopher name dropped them you know
like I was hanging out with so-and-so at
the so we know that guy was cooler than
him and we don't have his work the Dead
Sea Scrolls are an example you know
there's a very literate religion and
it's a very dry climate and so we assume
things are gonna last I don't know that
they are the quality of paper is
actually going down not up they used to
put a lot of care into paper it's like
canvases than what we have now I think
the best example of this is the Penguin
Classics Collection you can buy you can
go an Amazon and buy the all of them in
one fell swoop and they come in a truck
on pallets these the paper has acid in
it and someone who knows what they're
yeah you know talking about the quality
sucks and someone computed how long it
would take to read the entire set of
books if you ordered these and started
reading even if you had several people
helping you by the time you get to the
last one it's it's illegible because of
the acid in the paper so that's how long
that's gonna last all the Penguin
Classics in the world are gone pretty
soon after we stopped printing them the
quality of old paper is so good that we
can actually read washed ink off of we
found manuscripts that were like washed
off the paper and then a new text put on
top of it and we can use x-ray
crystallography to read the old text
it's pretty amazing the things that are
good for life are really bad for books
if we want books to be around while
there's still life around there's some
disagreement there
okay now this is I was gonna give that I
was gonna give a five-minute talk I was
gonna get to this point make this next
point and then I was gonna drop the mic
and walk out but I'm gonna stay for
drinks afterwards there's part of the
whole argument against digital is that
some that formats change over time and
we lose the the key to unlock those
formats I'll tell you why that's
ridiculous later but language and
permanence is an even worse problem so
this is why I think proprietary format
is overblown this is Luke chapter 2
verse 8 I I can't read these oh you're
not seen it yet I'm sorry I'm looking at
the wrong screen okay Luke chapter 2
verse 8 if anybody know hold English I'm
sure cameo does yeah you can read this
can you can you read the first line for
us you guys I'll get that
that's impressive give a round of
applause so and unless and unless we
keep him alive we're [ __ ]
so that's Old English in the middle we
have middle English which I only know
what this means because I I kind of know
what the last one means which is
Shakespearean that's let's look at the
years of this this is six hundred Common
Era not long ago let's go five hundred
years ahead and we got middle English
1100 Common Era and then Shakespearean
you know the shakespeare's age which
anybody who's been through college will
tell you that that stuff's not easy to
read either and it's only 500 years old
so every every 500 years I mean these
are really tough iterations and we're
talking ten thousand years so we've got
20 iterations of this this is a really
bad game at Chinese whispers and it
looks like Chinese to me by the time you
go through this so we'll talk about why
proprietary format is overblown but how
do we deal with this in 10,000 years no
one can read any of these and this is
only gonna I think accelerate as
languages start talking to each other
and as vernacular starts exploding with
technology all the popular culture
references in here will just be
gibberish like anyone who reads
Shakespeare and it's trying to get the
the contemporary Joe
so that's a huge problem that's language
and permanence I could walk out right
now and I've won I'm gonna give myself a
point I'm being objective about this to
other uses for books for paper so this
is another biggie everyone's familiar
with Maslow's hierarchy of needs it's a
it's a pyramid so start at the bottom
these are your base needs to keep you
alive the first two really are about
staying alive the next two are about
staying sane and the last one is
enlightenment
now let's look at if Maslow did a
hierarchy of books okay this is what
books are good for in this first stage
and this is what they were doing with
the Dead Sea Scrolls when we discovered
them there pull them out of an urn and
they're like that looks like it would
make good tinder and they were burning
them in fireplaces for heat it took I
don't know who that scholar who or
someone realized this might be important
and took it to a scholar they were
selling them somewhere else and making
money on the open market and then
somebody came in and said this [ __ ]
might be important so this is what
people gonna be doing with books while
we're suffering the digital Dark Age
that we're all scared of personal
security that's books are gonna be
burned this is all safety oh now why why
these two this is actually worse because
down here you've got people burning just
because they need fire up here and
they'll burn books if they find them up
here you've got fanaticism and religion
and you've got intolerance you've got
people trying to feel good about
themselves but they're not yet
enlightened this is when you go look for
books to burn them you know like where
are the books stored where we're gonna I
want to actually kind of take you on a
little history tour when I learned that
the that the Egyptian pyramids you know
there's two places that they put their
bodies the Pharaohs the the pyramids and
the valley of to the valley of the Dead
or whatever it's called a valley of
kings thank you
it's so cool being in a smart audience I
could just have you guys give this talk
I when I found out that the pyramids
came first that blew my mind it seemed
like the pyramids were an upgrade from
just finding a cave or a
and throwing a body and a bunch of gold
in it and then burying it and and
leaving them underground like that the
pyramid seemed like that would come next
right that's not the way it worked
because there was a dart gauge between
these two kingdoms and the pyramids were
like hey there's like really cool [ __ ]
in here and that's what's going to
happen with libraries when we go through
these stages especially if we put them
in mountains with big monuments on top
of them like we're discussing here with
the long now foundation someone's gonna
find out about this and say that's too
dangerous they're gonna seek it out and
then they're gonna use some of your
Molotov cocktails so yeah but but Xander
he made this point when he gave his talk
about digital books the best way to save
them is to lose them and and those are
the books I Will Survive not my one of
one editions which is sad and then Kevin
Kelly made a point earlier today with me
that the best storage solution are the
landfills where a lot of books are going
mostly Yale James and books like that so
when we get to where we are today we're
and we're only getting close to the
stage of enlightenment people are still
burning books for ideological reasons
but we have people like this who have
always been ahead of their time the
preserving books for the first time so
we have to get back to this stage before
we stop burning them so there's some
other uses for paper this is another big
one we know this libraries don't last
everyone talks about the Library of
Alexandria even though that story you
know is a little a little different than
the version we get so let's just look at
some of what's what's lost here 55,000
books in manuscript I just these are
some random ones that I've pulled up
170,000 volumes destroyed millions of
books lost in China and 400 see 8,000
rare books a lot of these there were no
other copies these are gone forever to
me when I was growing up and I lost my
way with my religion and adopted science
and wanted knowledge and got into books
and I found out about these libraries
that were lost to me like this is worse
than any loss of human life because
we're all going to die but to lose
knowledge that we built and and would
never have again plays things like that
was terror
fine the good news is I made all this
well that'd mean I make motor than most
of this [ __ ] up yeah I actually just
like random stuff the thing that I that
the thing that I kept though is what was
lost because these are the real dates
and places and this is just this is just
a sampling this is the ones that we know
about these in the last few years and
this is what was lost
Isis is mauling our heritage right now
books are target's this is just to drive
home that point of what books are going
to be good for and that we have to get
back to this stage not where we can turn
power on but where we can open our minds
back up so paper I don't know has some
disadvantages that we have to think
about some advantages to digital you
know these are everyone knows these
there's a lot you can make a lot of
copies to make them very dense
I think the salvage ability is a lot
better and I think there's an only
improve is technology improves I think
we're gonna get to the point where on
the nano level we're gonna be able to
read magnetic storage that right now we
think is lost one interesting thing to
me about looking at digital Dark Age
that's this term for like if we lost all
power or if we lost formats we wouldn't
be able to go back and get that
information I haven't found a case yet
where they really really wanted the data
and they weren't able to get it it's a
it's a matter of patience and cost this
is a big one this gets to the problem
with language that I showed every 500
years our translation software is
already getting decent but when it gets
great what I would like to see is the
digital library that makes a 100 year
iteration of every book so we'll shift
and dust and the Martian every hundred
years this software will say ok it's
been 100 years since this came out it
does the translation in seconds a time
stamp set and now you've got it updated
for the people of that age and for
language buffs imagine being able to
step back through time and read old
editions you go to the oldest Edition
and anything you don't understand you
can go to the next oldest one where you
understand it to bridge that gap and you
can get a that gives you as close as
possible to the original and will
preserve a lot of these languages and I
someone will have to work on this a bit
that that might not be doing it
and that that's thinking long-term
because we don't see language changing
day to day but it does change like we
just looked at that that Bible passage
this is why this is my favorite point
about digital and the fear of these
format losses no one's trying to hide
this data the data that we lose because
oh it's saved as a zip file and we don't
do zip files anymore like no one was
working really hard to make sure we
can't write this and if cryptography was
so easy that we could just write in a
format and then like kill the guy who
did the coding or move him to Alaska
then that's how we would do cryptography
and no one would ever be able to crack
it in fact it's really easy to crack
these formats we just make a big deal
out of it because it's annoying like
anybody who's had to upgrade like every
time windows 10 just came out of today
or yesterday or something and and they
brought the start button back but when
they changed something like that we all
wake out and I'm convinced that this is
where the the moved to like preserving
paper over digital came because of this
annoyance like what God if I can't open
this file that we had that we use in
accounting three years ago then we're
just totally screwed and I feel like
that's giving up too quickly there's so
many advantages to digital that we can
innovate and make it better
my favorite technology out right now for
this is m-disc which they're making for
archival purposes and it's a physical
etching it's better than the chemical
that we use for a CD are right now they
they assume a thousand years it's funny
how they have to extrapolate this
because it hasn't been around 1,000
years but I I think that this will
improve and we need to work on a 10k
solution for digital archival and then
that opens up all kinds of awesome
opportunities the the biggest thing
about digital if we if we preserve this
we're creating a zoo we're putting
individuals in a cage they can't talk to
each other and they don't interact with
each other once the machine learning
comes around and artificial intelligence
and we get we feed this digitally into
them that's where our collective
intelligence will will have life and so
by preserving the digital we preserve an
ecosystem when we preserve print we
preserve
individual species so this is an
excellent first step but it's the first
step we took when we created a zoo and
we had little cages and then we learn
later that books go crazy when they're
kept in cages
books books thrive when they're shared
and when they when they interact with
one another a couple of things I think
that we miss as people who write
post-apocalyptic fiction we always act
like they'll never be any power in these
worlds but though right now we are
covering the world in solid-state power
generators that will be less efficient
but power will be you know they'll be
able to set up like you know traps for
people and stuff they'll just be power
everywhere
matter of fact to preserve literature
one of the first things people will
realize is if they type in five five
three seven eight zero zero eight into a
calculator and turn it upside down it'll
say boobless and this this is something
that we will always preserve because
we'll have enough solar powered
calculators machines I think also await
the hierarchy of need better like a
thumb drive just doesn't look very
useful to people and going through their
primitive stages it's not like paper so
there's a chance that and and this is
something that's kind of cool and a lot
of post apocalyptic stuff where
something very important is being used
as an adornment you know and and I think
that will probably happen but thumb
drives they'll be earrings and things
like that that have like all of
humanity's knowledge and it and
meanwhile these people are like banging
rocks together another big point is that
by the time we need all this knowledge
by the time we need all of human
knowledge we're gonna have a lot of
human knowledge so our recovery ability
is gonna be great
our knowing what to look for decoding
any kind of primers to understand what's
being written again back to the Maslow's
hierarchy of books it's not until you
get to self-actualization that someone
is saying I want to know everything that
the people in the past and you and by
the time they get there we can assume
they're going to be more advanced than
us I think what do you think about that
oh you're saving okay you're making the
list I'm watching that scoreboard okay I
so these are these are all the
considerations that output into sitting
down and coming up with
at a lasting digital library and and
keep improving this as the tools improve
I think we could build them several
machines hundreds as affordable as
possible if you gave me X number of
dollars this would be the challenge if
you give me X number of dollars and I
had to preserve human knowledge how many
books could I store versus how many and
maybe several libraries of books and how
much could I use that same money to
build a library that would hold pretty
much everything that we've ever had one
of the problems I have with this
solution is that it's heavily curated
and we don't know what's going to be
important
the only reason Andy and I are authors
is because we bypass the curation
machine we even never have gotten
published had we not kind of broken the
rules the way we did so I'm sad to think
about what's going to be lost a lot of
books that never have a print edition at
all they're they're self-published in
digital form and it might be the best
thing ever written 500 years from now
and and if we don't save everything
we'll lose those these are basic things
that we're going to need you guys have
done some of this with the Rosetta
project how to get the stuff out of the
machines I think like projection to me
is the most obvious to have something
that you can read without having to have
moving parts something very robust but
the ability to project to display on the
device and maybe even to print copies
they have this espresso book machine now
it's about the size of a large printer
and it pops out a fully-formed book
well that survived 10,000 years I don't
know but maybe we can look into making
it robust enough to survive a thousand
so that as soon as things go to hell as
long as we've kept it maintained it'll
last long enough to get to bridge the
gap I think all of this should be open
source I think we should definitely do
the time stamp thing I love that idea
and I think it's off to be crowd-sourced
one thing you could do for instance with
the long now foundation is create a
thumb drive that had what you thought
was important maybe as much of this as
in copyright or public domain I would
give you the rights to have my digital
edition on there and sell them to people
make enough to have a profit to support
the
now foundation but then everyone has you
know then you have tens of thousands of
copies of these thumb drives out there
which improves the chances that we find
these things and you can plug it into
your computer anytime you want and it'll
do an update you know refresh it I think
there's a moral imperative to this when
you look at what what's important about
us is what we've learned over time
none of us important are really
important individually despite what
Xander thinks about himself but our
ideas are we don't want to lose those
they're very important language is great
at preserving ideas writing preserves
our language so that we can read
people's ideas well after they're gone
libraries preserve writing that's why
this is important you guys know that I
think this is more important than the
money we're pumping into seed vaults
which is admirable but I think language
is gonna or nature is gonna take care of
herself but that the only one is going
to preserve language preserve knowledge
is us what's cool is that I'm not the
only person at thinking about this
people have been thinking about this for
over 20 years and there's all these
projects underway these are just a
handful a lot of money going into this
and so there's a lot of duplication you
know they these guys all talk to each
other there's conferences about this and
how to improve methods and I guess you
guys are going to have your own version
at some point right of like a digital
library okay the last thing I'll say I
won't say there's Andrus wrong about any
of this and I'm really honored to have
my books up there and if I was investing
in something that's important I would I
would definitely diversify my portfolio
there's pros and cons to both I think
they're gonna augment each other I think
when they get to 3,500 and start
replacing books might not probably be
the first ones to go and I yeah I I'm
more optimistic upon than most I think
if we do lose power it won't be for long
this was cruel this is Zander slipped
this in on me
and uh it's pretty clever so I'll give
him a point for that
oh look at that so there you go you get
yeah so I I love that I love that the
chalk the chalk drawler died that was
excellent I sabotage that so that's um
that's why that's why I think digital
has advantages that pen doesn't I love
to hear Xander's rejoinder and then
we'll do some Q&A with the rest of you
guys and if you want it if hey good Wow
it's it's 8 o'clock exactly I was trying
to sneak that in at 30 minutes but I
know everyone here I talked to before
the talk was interested in talking about
anything but this so we can take some ya
know we've tricked people into talking
about digital preservation who all came
here to ask you questions about the
apocalypse so so we will do questions
about the apocalypse shortly don't worry
but we're gonna just I think just flesh
out a couple of these ideas because I do
think that you know that the wind as I
mentioned back in 98 when we really
started thinking about digital
preservation we were looking at digital
the digital history up to that point
which was rough was very rough and as as
you know there's that you know that the
original tapes from the Apollo landing
which were saved by like accident after
accident after accident there was one
woman who kept them in and McDonald's on
the base and if she hadn't done that and
then gone through painstaking work to
guess that a digital copiers had a
physical copy that they were digital no
but it's on active yeah well well yes
that's an interesting question yes yes
and this is the problem that plagues the
early like Star Wars little time yeah I
don't think we'll ever have a blu-ray of
the original Star Wars films because
Lucas raped the original by adding a
bunch of digital monsters and they did
it on their own the celluloid they
painted they painted and on the physical
thing and so that's gone and it's a kind
of a physical loss if we digitized it
before they had before Lucas raped it
then yeah doctor here's another one or
argon what's the what's the doctor to
you story they
hundred and eight episodes were lost and
they were because they were on film it's
too bad we can't do that with friends
yeah so they I mean we do have stories
where there's that where the physical
media got lost and so there was this
time before where before storage was
free yeah which it is now so as long as
we call that free right so and and I'm
not sure I want to call that free yet
but I think that you know now we have at
least we live in an ecosystem where
digital is free for for a while and you
know and then there's the $4.99 for like
10 terabytes right well no that's
Dropbox or whatever it is definitely way
cheaper than printing that at Kinkos
yeah 10 terabytes worth of data so
that's gonna be the I think the the
question and I think you know long now
was looking at a lot of those early kind
of horror stories and and even more
modern ones Pixar's Toy Story 2 the
digital version a sysadmin typed RM - R
star and wiped out their entire Toy
Story - right before they finished it
and was there was some random backup
that they were able to pull back out
that saved it there's a great there's
actually a great little animation of
that of that story so they had a free
backup they were just able to like they
thought it was gone gone it was a it was
a it was actually a fluke it was
somebody who had put it on their pity it
was an employee yes right so an illegal
employee backup saved Toy Story 2 that
that's what we need to like sell those
thumb drives that's right but it'd be so
cool to like have a little capsule that
you knew was like a copy of everything
that we know and we're not there yet but
like we tend to take our current
technology and I think we have at least
maybe 50 years before the world implodes
and in 50 years if things continue the
way they are storage is going to be
ridiculous what a thumb drive will hold
would probably be like the Internet so
we'll see maybe not maybe not in 50
years but certainly in 100 or 500 and
yeah I mean it could happen kind of for
any number of reasons and I think but
the question of you know a complete
societal collapse that stops all
spinning desks is a pretty big that's
that's pretty big requirement how do you
see that happening because this all
presupposes like the the fear that we're
gonna lose everything digitally means
that we lose civilization for a while I
mean I think the only thing that's on
that scale is is comment impact or
meteor impact so we put a copy on the
moon we put a copy on Mars we leave
directions a big sign like maybe put it
right on the middle of that face on Mars
I know doesn't look like a face from
every other angle and problem solved
right
ya know every we sent one of our rosetta
disks on a spacecraft and you can send a
military on commentary
you know trajectory so that they keep
just come back yeah which is a certainly
another tactic and those could be
digital and the new the New Horizons
spacecraft they're replacing its data
banks with messages from Earth the
digital version of the Voyager record so
that'll actually be an interesting test
see if it's still too long can you read
the Voyager record versus how long can
you read the the digital version which
will have way more data on it but we'll
be in a digital format so that's an
interesting question are there any
questions from the audience I'm gonna
repeat the question so people can hear
it so yeah
the promise dude you don't necessarily
need a collapse of civilization but
maybe you just need at some point of
time people in nationalization simply
deemed that some material is not worth
keeping
yeah right well yeah so I think and to
some of the points that we saw earlier
so you know when you have the
ideological destruction of data
we're actually I think vastly more
vulnerable to that now than we were then
we are with books because books actually
take a lot of effort to burn whereas our
M - our star you know at a national
library could devastate you know for the
same reason you can store that many
books in one place you can also
devastate those books yeah in a single
command yeah so I think we need you know
as many copies as possible in as many
places as possible and hide some lose
some store some jet and some III think
this is like one of the most important
things we can do right now is every I
don't how many years you want to pick
every 20 or 50 years like encapsulate
all that we've learned and put it out
there right well and I think I mean even
more than the encapsulation the physical
media I mean the thing that we did when
we did this conference in 1998 at the
getty center on on digital preservation
is there was a whole thing that happened
happened yet the internet basically
right I mean there was there was the
beginnings of it but it wasn't on this
scale that it is now we're fundamentally
you know people have normalized all of
their data into one format yeah that
fits that works and is read on the
internet and that's the that's the big
paradigm shift is it used to be that
there were all these isolated silos of
data that were not interconnected
yeah and now they are interconnected at
least a lot of the very valuable things
of course copyright has kind of broken
some of that to a certain extent Andy
has another one he can he get his guys
out of any trouble I don't
we disagreed the fact that place every
copyright holder has been trying three
very hard to destroy the illegal file
sharing internet kind of stops things
from being destroyed but I think that so
that's definitely true of popular
interesting things with a hobby group
it's like but not necessarily let's say
I mean the the one that came up I think
and it came up in our 1998 conference
and Jared Lanier at an interesting
solution it's the it's the mundane data
so you know it would be really awesome
if we had all the accounting of ancient
Rome and we definitely don't have all
the accounting from twenty years ago
and so Jaron Lanier years ago is not as
interesting as ancient Rome in many ways
it was the early digital history of our
planet right so and Journal in ears idea
was to create a is to be hobby groups
for boring things which I thought was an
interesting
one of the software testers access to
the entire accidentally our entire our
entire system that's not so quaint about
digital is that erasing a digital hard
drive is not so easy as just hitting
delete like if it was to government's
went in right random ones and zeros and
then put them through a grinder and turn
them into dust because if you had the
money and the you really want it badly
you can get it back yeah there might
even Pixar probably had a problem of
fidelity like they probably could have
gotten a lot of information back but it
wouldn't have been high def information
but getting it back load F is pretty
easy I think right and I think you know
that's that is the question of how bad
do you want it and then do you know more
about than just handcuffs can you get
like data out of things to like a hacker
as well Kevin
[Music]
[Music]
so yeah the question is yeah does the
non open source does the proprietary
format environment that we now live in
was a huge danger well I hope this
project would be an open source and a
crowdsource project that it wouldn't be
something that Google was in charge of
but something that a group like long now
was in charge of and that individuals
were in charge of I see this as being a
hobbyist thing and that a lot of people
really geeked out about being a part of
the preservation effort
I really think you can get the way you
guys have gotten the community involved
in a lot of these issues is to turn them
on to ideas like this and by selling you
know the the FOB or by making a physical
representation of what you're doing that
they can own then there's a conversation
going on what is that thing that you
wear from your ear around your neck or
on your keychain what do you keep on
there oh I keep I keep all of Wikipedia
on here and every now and then I plug it
in and it updates with all the new
Wikipedia articles I I trust
organizations like Wikipedia right now
and I think there will always be
organizations like that around that we
can trust but yeah when someone's motto
when a company's motto is don't do evil
I assume they're they're evil Fox
don't look over here actually the former
CTO of Wikipedia is asking you a
question oh I thought you good
I thought you gonna say Google I was
like [ __ ] Timmy's here oh yeah careful
spoilers before he dies I'm kidding I'm
kidding I was just making those this is
after the vampires yep I know you
mmm right and Neil Gaiman brought this
up in his talk of the person in the in
the concentration camp who read who
memorized a chapter of Gone with the
Wind each night and then recited it back
during sewing class because they weren't
allowed to read books oh right and
actually I think there's a good point so
as Denis and this is not giving away
anything in the book cuz you kind of
opened with this premise is that the
server's of the silos were purposefully
scrambled and no one knows why yeah so
their digital history was erased is the
premise of the book yet later on other
types of things are found right but the
digital history was a race but then a
good coder and you how to under a sit
once the zeroes are still there so I
think but yeah those paper and you know
the paper was I don't know artificially
limited because it's it's just a really
bad storage medium it is it's nice paper
any other questions is Andrew
yeah yeah I think I think he's asking
about flash drives and is that going to
be a proprietary format or not I think
what we're storing a nun will change
over time we're going to update it as we
go
the day that we have the apocalypse then
whatever is left by the time they can
figure out how to interface it this is
going back to the by the time we need
all knowledge we'll have much knowledge
they're gonna be more advanced than us
or as advanced as we are before they
need it and we're pretty clever at
getting stuff out like I know this is a
paper example but this is how clever we
are the getting the erased manuscript
off of a piece of parchment we're gonna
have that same ingenuity when we're
trying to recover digital and so I don't
worry about that someone can build a
machine well if we can build a thing
that will have draw a hot choc diagram
you know we'll be able to interface with
the flash drive well I mean my
understanding is flash drives they
basically they lose about half their
data just by entropy by ten years there
are some some of the new some of the
technologies that would be more next
flash drives kind of accidentally there
their technology is writing kind of
holographically the way stone does
inside its crystal structure and could
accidentally last for millions of years
but it's only it's it's a market force
that's driving that so that one may we
don't really know what's what's possible
we know that right now it erases to the
point that we can't read it but this
gets back to the crystallography with
the old manuscript there might be a
trace there on a you know on a quantum
level that we're not even aware of yet
yeah and then the question is do we know
to read it and you know that the you
know the rosetta stone was found by one
of Napoleon's soldiers and actually knew
that it was important as they could see
it but you know if you found a broken
piece of a DVD you know it might be
shiny but would you know there's data on
it isn't interesting well what's your
joinder to the language issue because
well know to read these in 10,000 years
and we won't be able to because he's not
gonna be here right well so yeah I mean
the language issue is the reason we
the very first long-term storage thing
we did was a language key but we don't
know I mean ya know it includes versions
of English as well 10,000 years from now
well not yet
now impressive we still have to we still
have you know there's the emoji version
comes next week and Ryan your question
I'm hoping it's protein or yeah I
[Music]
haven't rolled it I think that's that'll
be the answer like right now digital is
the best thing we have and then the
future to be something better
I love DNA stores and the idea that we
could have a library that is growing and
renewing itself and multiplying but I
know I think a thousand years from now
this is all going to be seemed moot like
of course this is how we do it it's not
gonna be paper though it's gonna be
whatever comes next
right I think this is a finalized entire
book into the junk DNA right and
actually Jaron Lanier another idea that
Darren linear had that he's submitted to
the the save a hundred years of the New
York Times project was to put that into
the junk DNA of cockroaches and breed
them endemically and to preserve your
population of cockroaches so you asked
me why would someone think to look into
a flash drive but someone's gonna think
to look in the cockroach DNA first well
we spend a lot of time looking at
cockroach DNA where's my chalk
Wow yes I love that right so book
viruses but Jeff Jeff Bezos is working
on making these fly these are gonna be
flying to you right now these book
viruses are a great idea I love that
idea
I'm in on that thanks for that email
bite and I think this this techno phobia
is where a lot of the fear of digital
data comes from because we you know we
also have the are the unfortunate
generation that lived through the
transition of this and you know there's
my daughter's generation will just think
of it as turning on lights yeah
and I think that's the question and
fundamentally long I was not against
digital data we're not we're not you
know this is our first collection of
books but our our main goal was to kind
of call out some of the dangers of
digital and I think that fundamentally
these are all gonna have kind of a relay
race and marathon race kind of
characteristic to them where some things
are gonna last a long time and I think
that one of the points that you brought
up about the gateway factor of print is
a huge one and it came up when we were
trying to collect this collection we're
trying to get all the great works of
humanity plus wolf and yeah even even
well and but when we when you do that if
you look at the last thousand years of
literature there's basically you know no
women there's no there's almost nobody
of color there's I mean it's it's so it
that gateway has kept people out of that
for so long that there's a new thing
that you know people minorities or
people underrepresented groups their
stuff could get found as you point out
now in a new way
yeah and I'm writing stuff that will
probably never be in print like I'm
writing stuff now that I'm just
uploading in digital form in their short
stories that'll never be in an anthology
never be in a magazine and fortunately
it'll be lost completely if you're right
but if you've wanted it saved and you
think prints the only way to do it
there's a lot of stories out there now
that have no chance because they'll
never will never be a physical edition
so if this is important then let's let's
just engineer solutions listen this you
know and not give up on it I guess oh
yeah yeah this is uh I don't know if
there's a great service called called
pedia press where you can print out any
article in Wikipedia so this is a
two-volume set of the nature entry and
so and there's a there's a group that's
printed this the whole Wikipedia out
like this right but we have a few of
them here and and so what's beautiful
about these is that if I printed this
today it's a different version yeah
but you get to put it up on up on your
shelf so there's actually a bunch of
them that are kind of pre done but they
they print out beautifully and you can
get them in color or not or just that
you can also just just get the digital
version so I think we should make a long
bet and it can either be about your book
or maybe one of these books okay and
which one which one will last longer the
digital version let's do that what's
that let's do with wool with wool yeah
bring that one down to me I'm gonna
start right now we have a bunch of
copies in the back so we'll do a couple
more questions and then and then we'll
we'll disband and you can all bring your
books up here to get signed and then
we'll have some drinks I think drink and
assaults to with more questions yes now
what
yeah well it to be fair at his talk
started about text but yes the we're all
those things get into those are those
are vastly more complex things you know
when you get it even just a basic
program that's not text well I think
it's important to digitize those things
and to do a scan of the great classic
paintings that are generating everyday
and thus can be so good like on
millimeter waves that if we recreated it
we would have the texture of every brush
stroke of these great masters instead no
one's even trying to do this as far as I
know of getting the depth of the piece
as well instead of just a good print
he's doing it with the but it's a smart
guy see this is an idea I just had all
the top of my head and probably took
Bill Gates weeks to come up with that
and it just came to me like that
he's been hold on I already it's a few
people that haven't had a chance
are you an editor York at a major
publishing house er right how valuable
are the reddit comments versus the
digital volumes getting published and
the 4chan comments yes I mean but I
think the I mean you can go ahead answer
this but I also think that in the
digital world they're kind of free to
store either way if we just store it not
only that we are we gonna know what
we're stupid compared to people 50 years
100 years 500 years from now I I'm
really lucky you know that that the
tastes were where they were from my work
to do well but I could have been the
peak ad that I dreamed of being in order
to get through my writing where I was
gonna take a thousand years but people
to recognize my genius yeah I mean one
of the things we came across early on is
that librarians routinely excise ad
pages out of magazines when they store
them for archiving yeah which is like
which is you have to keep well there's
nothing cooler than getting at 1972
playboy and yeah looking at the I
subscribe for the ads yes like many of
you all right well with that thank you
all for coming and please grab a buck
and have them sign thank you very much
[Music]